marcellin nadeau bonjourbonjour
christine du pit bonjour à toutes celles
et ceux qui nous écoutent et
singulièrement aux gens du nord martine
cazes martinique et en général alors
vous êtes candidat aux élections
législatives où vous présenter sur la
liste pays a alors pour une première
candidature à ce scrutin qu'est ce qui a
motivé annoncé la troisième candidature
je veux dire qu'on connaît ma constance
mon engagement au profit de la
martinique et du nord en particulier
engagement qui fait que je suis arc
bouté à des valeurs j'ai une vision de
vision au levant de l'écologie politique
et cette défense intransigeante de mon
pays de son identité et de la justice
sociale donc c'est logiquement avec pays
a que je me présente à ces élections
d'autant que nous sommes face à une
situation particulièrement préoccupante
préoccupations qui relève d'éléments
conjoncturels faire découlant de la
politique menée par monsieur marc rond
pendant cinq ans avec bon les attaques
contre les plus défavorisés mais une
difficulté à relever l'exigence le défi
climatique notamment mais une politique
extrêmement répressive de saint
guillaume à l'endroit des soignants et
je tiens à exprimer ma solidarité à
l'endroit des soignants puisque j'étais
contre le la vaccination obligatoire et
je dis qu'il n'est pas normal que des
pères et des mères de familles soient ce
point sanctionné au détriment de leur
famille au détriment de nos conditions
de vie alors que parallèlement nous
avons besoin de ces personnels qui a
rendu temps de service et puis à côté de
ces éléments structurels il ya aussi des
éléments conjoncturels que nous
connaissons le chômage endémique la
question des inégalités territoriales
la question c'est dépollution les
pollutions notamment le chlordécone mais
les pesticides en général parce qu'on
est confronté un cocktail de pesticides
la question des sargasses la question de
l'eau la question des déplacements et du
développement économique bref toute une
série de questions structurelles mais ce
qui est plus préoccupant c'est que face
à cette situation avec des éléments
conjoncturels et structurels
on a quand même en quelques parents un
vide
l'idéologie régresse on voit aussi la
combi nation qui domine les alliances
bizarre et je crois que face à cela dans
cette confusion politique générale ap ya
nous proposons des perspectives claires
ou ce pays mais qui ne relève pas
seulement d'une élection législative
mais qui relève d'une vision globale que
nous avons pour le pays que nous
déclinons à chaque élection y compris
ces élections là parce que nous pensons
qu on est aussi dans une contexte
favorable avec ce rassemblement de la
gauche qui peut nous offrir des
principes et des perspectives d'un
gouvernement de cohabitation en mesure
de prendre les mesures nécessaires en
faveur des plus démunis et les plus
défavorisés et bien sûr de l'écologie
alors si vous êtes élu vous êtes partie
des députés de cette assemblée nationale
quelles sont pour vous d'après vous les
deux ou trois dossiers sur lesquels il
faudra immédiatement plancher alors nous
avons fait 5 grosse priorité que senghor
urgence monsieur climatiques écologiques
la santé le social
l'économie ce sont des priorités mais on
va mettre le son sur deux ou trois
urgences la santé par exemple la
question de la désertification médicale
de l'offre de soins notamment
singulièrement de l'ozone la nécessité
qu'il y ait effectivement d'avoir un
vrai service public de la santé et nous
parlons nous de démocratie médicale et
nous disons que cette exigence de
démocratie medica fait que lorsqu'il n'y
a pas suffisamment d'offre de soins
venant ou de la médecine de ville ou de
l'aude et d'établissements publics que
nous défendons cela les établissements
publics hospitaliers et bien nous posons
le principe de l'obligation d'installer
des maisons de la santé
pluridisciplinaires donc la question de
la santé la question si de
l'alimentation de l'agriculture
comment mettre à disposition de jeunes
agriculteurs pour développer une
agriculture nourricière mais comme on
s'est posé la question de la
réorientation du financement de
l'agriculture et puis bien sûr il y à
toutes ces questions sociales on
pourrait évoquer le les revenus des
personnes âgées les conditions de vue
des personnages et la nécessité de
mettre au coeur de des dispositifs de
services à la personne l'économie
sociale qu'il faut absolument relancer
qu'il faut soutenir qu'il faut
accompagner et ce que je voudrais quand
même dire avec deux éléments essentiels
le premier élément c'est la question des
serbes des services publics notamment
dans le nord où il faut à mon avis
décorrélée la question de la démographie
des deux de la location de dotation
parce que c'est le serpent qui se mord
la queue on est dans un cercle vicieux
qui fait que quand on a moins ce
d'habitants on a moins de dotations et
comme on a moins de dotations n'a du mal
au niveau des communes on a du mal de
rôles pour de relance est justement
l'attractivité des territoires et puis
aussi cette question la transversalité à
rechercher parmi les sujets quand je
prends la question urgente pour nous que
la question de la transition énergétique
il ya un enjeu quand même c'est celle
qui relève du développement économique
endogène parce qu'on le voit dans le
nord atlantique alors après la
monoculture de la banale on passe à nous
nos activités de la transition
énergétique avec l'implantation de
nombreuses fermes éoliennes non nous
disons que ça va il faut pas justement
il faut de l'agilité économique il faut
diversification justement de notre
économie et singulièrement dans le
secteur des énergies renouvelables où il
faut il faut aller vers un mix
énergétique plus qu'une vieille
monoculture en rupture avec la
nécessaire autoconsommation matière
d'énergie et puis je crois que
effectivement il faut il faut absolument
que nous soyons dans une démarche
participative d' écoute des gens des
coûts des habitants et nous proposons
très clairement une fois élu de mettre
en place ce que nous appelons dans le
cadre d'une démocratie participative
un conseil de législature avec des
délégués des communes qui nous
permettront d'être en dialogue permanent
avec les habitantes et les habitants de
la circonscription
alors qu'avez vous à dire aux électeurs
pour les convaincre de voter pour vous
et votre liste alors de voter pour moi
et ma suppléante qui et cynthia iru une
marie goutines jeune mike bottines de 30
ans très engagée dans l'action solidaire
et caritatif qui a obtenu d'ailleurs à
ce titre un prix prodige de la
république donc avec elle nous allons
effectivement ne seront pas ce que nous
sommes nous sommes déterminés à gagner
parce que gagner pour nous c'est
redonner espoir c'est réenchanter la
politique donner une certaine espérance
aux gens qu'ils sont désespérés quand on
voit le taux d'abstention ans quelle que
soit pas notre victoire sera comme le
tonnerre qui éclaircira le ciel
politique martiniquais quand on est
confronté à trop de confusion dans ce
monde politique martiniquais marcellin
nadeau merci merci c'est moi